hello everyone and welcome back to the
day two of the uh magnus carlson
invitational knockouts it's wesley saw
versus saliresa ferruccia and this is
game two of their match game one ended
in a draw
uh and if you remember from yesterday uh
uh wesley really crushed elereza he won
the first two games and
ended the third one in a draw to claim
the match and now
wesley is on a on a very nice path to
winning
uh the uh well winning the semi-finals
uh sorry the quarterfinals and the
qualifying for the semifinals and this
is one extremely impressive game
features a move that
uh well it's just one of those moves
that you want to you know immediately
tell about your
friends in the bar and the library uh
and that being said let's check out the
game so can
first bounce back or will wesley just
take it all so wesley with the white
pieces
opens with e4 and ferruja again tries
what he tried yesterday and that is c6
he goes for the karo khan defense
uh sorry about that uh we have d for by
wesley
and d5 so let's see if alireza repeats
what he did yesterday we have d5 and e5
going for the advanced variation of the
karo khan
bishop to f5 and now knight to f3 so
everything the same not going for
anything crazy
uh we have e6 and now bishop to e2 so
wesley sticks to what he played
yesterday we have knight to e7 and here
we have castles we have h6 by ferruja
uh and now it's actually wesley who
deviates from the
their yesterday's game uh then a4 was
played but here was the continuous
knight to b to d2
and now he asks first how he will
continue the game we have knight beat to
d7
and wesley now shifts the knight the
knight back to b3
and now preparing ideas like a485 that's
similar to what he did yesterday so here
g5
furuja also expands here on the king
side now
knights the g6 can be played also he has
a very nice support for f6
if he wants to break the center uh and
here
uh knights the e1 there is a game where
uh
this was played but here we have bishop
to d2 by wesley
uh we have a5 and now a4 uh we have
queen to c7
uh the nicely developing the queen uh
adding more preparation to this f6 idea
and now there is one game in the
database where rook the c1 was played it
was played in the uh 2015 feed a world
cup in baku
uh between america and fabiano corona
fabi was able to win that game
but here we have c3 and uh it is as of
this c3 movie 11 that we have a
completely new game
uh so here uh much like in the
yesterday's game already
strikes in the center with f6 with e
captures on f6 knight to g6
now preparing to capture this because
you don't want to allow uh this knight
to easily come to e5 so first
knight to g6 uh and now uh well
yesterday we saw f7 in a similar
position but here now we don't have that
we have actually c4 so now what happens
here firuja goes bishop to d6 continues
development
uh and now uh now we have what is uh
well what is showcased in the thumbnail
we have c captures
on d5 e captures on e5 and now we have
this amazing amazing position where
wesley has
uh this god tier move that i am so very
very impressed with so feel free to
pause the video and try to find wesley's
idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations you
you you definitely have a bright future
in chess and for those who just want to
enjoy the show it's
bishop the d3 just like that offering a
full piece
uh and although although of course black
can just capture this
it's uh even more complicated if black
decides not to capture this because how
do you save this bishop
there really is no good way to do it you
could play bishop some like bishop to e4
but this is just crazy i will just show
you some
a little bit of what happens if you play
bishop to e4 so we would get bishop
caltrans on e4 d captures and now knight
the e5
going after the knight and g6 and now
okay black uh
doesn't mind black can very happily
capture in the center knight d
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and now
bishop captures on e5
but now comes knight to c5 and here you
can see that
black really has a lot of problems and
it's not
not at all clear what you do here you
could capture on h2 with check there's
always that so let's see what happens
there bishop capture so we
check king the h1 and your king is still
in the center of the board
not much you can do here so let's say
you decide to castle queen side here
well
now the problem is this knight's the e6
move that forks the rook and the queen
and the white just wins material
and it's gonna uh whistle will have a
much better game so instead of castling
queenside here
you might continue with bishop back to
e5 just a nice safety move
but then queen to g4 cutting off the
king from castling queen side
and now after bishop captures on f6
let's say now you get
this queen captures an e4 check
connecting with the knight here so you
have to block 97
and now rook f2 e1 and again what do you
play here
there's not all that much you can do if
you castle then again we have this knife
the e6 move forking the queen and the
rook
and if you don't castle i mean look at
this position it's just uh
uh well how do you play this you could
castle queen side but still queen e6
check picks up the bishop on f6 so
even that's not playable uh so after
this bishop to d3
alireza has quite a lot to consider but
bishop to e4 simply doesn't work so all
it is is all right let's capture the
bishop
and this is in fact the best move so
bishop captures on d3 was played
and now bishop captures an a5 this is
the plan
attacking the queen and preparing queen
captures on d3 and connecting with the
knight and g6 this is uh
amazing stuff so rook captures on a5
grabbing that bishop and now queen
captures on d3
and now the knight and the rook are
under attack here
so you have to save uh one of them of
course you're not going to give up a
full piece so king to f7 has to be
played
and now knight captures on a5 we have
queen captures on a5 and now
queen to f5 uh what do you what do you
play here
now the rooks are coming to the e1
either of the rook can come here knight
to e5 will be very strong if it happens
so here we have queen back to b8 the
queen
needs to help out with with the defense
here now going after this pawn
uh if you're wondering why not just
capture the pawn right away well it's
very much too dangerous because now
you've removed one of the defenders of
the e5 square
knight the e5 check is just deadly you
have to capture otherwise queen captures
and g6 is happening
so after knight captures pawn captures
now you have a nice double attack here
and
there's just not nothing you can do here
uh so instead after queen to f5
uh with uh alersa goes back queen to d8
and
now rook a to e1 the other rook can also
come to e1
uh matter of preference really and now
again what do you play here we have uh
well you have to prevent a
queen to e6 check that's going to be
deadly so firuja decides to go for a
knight at
f8 now guarding the e6 square but now
you allow something else in wesley
wesley is just relentless here he goes
rook to e7 with check
continuing the attack in the greatest
possible way and you don't really have
anything here if
you move the king it's made in one so uh
rook to g7 would be checkmate
so what uh alireza did here is of course
he captured with bishop captures on a7
check without check uh pawn captures on
e7 with
check uh you have to now capture the
pawn otherwise you just lose a queen so
king captures
and now comes rook the e1 with check
king to d6
there's nothing better and now knight to
e5 and here
there again is very very little you can
do knight to f7 would be a nice royal
fork here forking the king and the queen
so rook to h7
the only good move for alireza and now
comes knight
captures on d7 and here the problem is
even though the material is now sort of
equal white is up only one pawn the
position is
completely winning for white because
there is no good move here i will show
you
even if alireza replies in the best
possible way uh which is rook to e7
uh it's still uh well uh
an effortless victory for for wesley
because here he just trades and that's
it
rook captures queen captures and now
just queen captures here with uh
well with a nice pin so you can't really
move uh king captures on d7 and now
captures and captures and here we have
this end game
where white is up upon with pawns on
both sides of the board it's a
completely winning ending game for white
and both of them know this so
obviously alireza did not go for that
alireza played queen captures on d7
instead
but now it's even worse because of
course now you'll see what happens
uh wesley actually has a checkmate in
one and of course wesley played it he
played queen to e5 with
checkmate uh and of course uh well it
was in this position on
26th that the game ended with checkmate
so
it's a uh you know a very standard idea
when you
when the queen checks the king
diagonally and these two squares are
covered so if you check on a dark square
you have to always
watch if the light squares are covered
and then it's always checkmate
because the king will not have anywhere
to go maybe maybe a nice
thing to remember but yeah really an
impressive
impressive showing by wesley i really
crushed alireza uh defeated him uh two
games yesterday and
uh well uh a draw and today also uh one
won two games and drew one game so
really a crushing
uh victory for wesley and what a game
and what
what a showing that uh bishop to d3 move
simply insane
uh i wasn't um uh i came i came back
home
uh from uh from the capitol a bit late
today so i missed the first round and
then i had to you know get back into it
to cover
uh we'll check out all of the games that
were played and i kept
getting messages on on my twitter on my
facebook on my you know pretty much
everything you know
bishop d3 bishop d3 i'm like what's
bishop d3 then i saw what it is i'm like
okay
bishop to d3 yeah so thank you for
uh suggesting it everyone yeah it's
definitely
one of those moves that you want to
share with everyone
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank um
uh mr future uh jan hogerverf
i love mati kevin hawkins and kd nuggets
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day